he's Mike Tirico today marks 100 days
out from the Winter Olympics in South
Korea and Mike will be the main host
there and he joins us from South Korea
can you give us a weather and traffic
update Mike I can DP it's a 1035 in the
evening so traffic is light in
Pyeongchang it's probably 48 degrees
it's not too bad I'm standing right in
front of the ice hockey venue I'm
looking at speed skating and short track
speed skating across the way so they're
in pretty good shape actually saw a
bunch of the events venues in the
mountains today and there are some test
events going on up the sliding area so
unlike Sochi four years ago
it looks like Pyongyang is ready for the
games to start on time with not too many
wet paint signs is there Buffalo Wild
Wings in Pyeongchang I have not seen one
however in the Seoul Airport first thing
we saw Krispy Kreme Doughnuts travel all
the way across the across the world for
Krispy Kreme donuts and the hot sign was
on there was a neon light are you able
to watch American sports over there
you know not in the hotel where we are
but as we were driving around looking at
venues today we were watching Game six
of the World Series on our phone so yes
we're looking at the sliding track this
morning and we're watching Korea at the
plate for the Astros and get the out to
v8 and all that stuff so it it's
actually pretty bizarre it's whatever
Thursday Tuesday morning over here and
we're watching or Wednesday morning
would have been and we're watching Game
six and tomorrow morning will be the car
somewhere and you're watching Game seven
which is pretty cool
what do you want to I hit on as far as
sports wise do you want to do Olympics
or do you want to do some of the other
things anything that's a hot-button item
for you I will do anything you want to
do rapid-fire I will cover as much as
you want because you're my friend
it's you're a fan and you're not you
don't have a particular interest rooting
interest who are you rooting for tonight
Dodgers or Astros
a little bit of me says Astros let's see
the team that hasn't wanted when it have
that moment obviously Houston's gone
through a very few tough few couple of
months we understand LA and the Dodgers
it's been so long and all of that but if
you're a neutral fan I think perhaps
Houston story to see a franchise win and
get that first one up there Notre Dame
you Notre Dame's number three in the
college football committee rankings
there you're you're calling the Notre
Dame game they lost to Georgia at home
which has turned out to be a good loss
because Georgia's number one but how
good is this Notre Dame team considering
what they have ahead of them it's one of
those days every week you say okay this
is a test this is a test and I pass it I
think when I saw the standings come out
last night for you this morning for us
over here in Korea when I saw North
Carolina State USC seems that notre dame
just dismantled back-to-back weeks and
they're still in the top 20 of the
rankings based on what they've done
their seasons body of work that ensures
for me that this is a very good nerd a
team they run it their offensive lines
very good Josh Adams having a great year
running back stories defense Mike elko
the defensive coordinator came over from
Wake Forest he's done a really good job
with these players and they're forcing
turnovers getting the offense off the
feet are back on the field getting the
opposing offense off the field so I
think they are legit I know anybody can
lose it's still a quarter the seasons
ago or third of the season it's November
but I think they do everything you need
to do to sustain against the best teams
to the country and we saw that in the
Georgia game do you think Notre Dame
still has that cachet that if it comes
down to Notre Dame or Oklahoma or Notre
Dame or TCA or Wisconsin Notre Dame is
going to get the nod because it's Notre
Dame and it's better for TV III think
it's changed a little bit Dan I still
think there's a cachet to Notre Dame a
national appeal to it but I think
because conferences have become so
powerful it changes the calculus of all
of us well let's just play this out I
know people have done this but Alabama
and Georgia are clearly one and two and
they play an unbelievable one-point game
for the ages the SEC title game you're
gonna say well they're two of the best
four teams they go nor deams eleven and
one they're going to go
that would mean that only one of the big
ten big 12 ACC or pac-12 champs would go
leaving three of the five big
stakeholders out that just shows you
what a poor system they've set up and
I'd be the great test to see if their
name still has that cachet and the
independence of the people making this
decision he's Mike Tirico joining us
from South Korea were a hundred days out
until the start of the Olympics give
people an idea that you're moving into a
pretty big chair maybe the greatest
sports caster of our time and Bob Costas
you're now the host of the Olympics the
pressure you feel the preparation that
you're gonna have to go through in the
next hundred days is what the
preparation I'm trying to do a little
bit every week I'm not trying to hold it
till January and start cramming I'm
trying to do some every week which is a
little more challenging doing a football
game every week and work with you on
Sunday nights on the studio end of
football night so it's it's something I
had to commit to okay you know what
we're gonna take three hours and go
through speed skating we take three
hours and go through biathlon and those
other things each week so it's not
January 8th and I'm starting from the
very beginning the pressure part yeah
I'll be honest with you of course you're
gonna be compared to everybody who does
anything now is compared by everyone to
the last person who just did it and to
be compared as you said to somebody who
is as good as it will ever get in that
chair and on TV that's that's fine I'm
comfortable enough that I've done TV
long enough to bring my own set of
sensibilities and I have advice from Bob
and from Al Michaels and from you when I
did the daytime stuff a couple years ago
take the segment at a time you can't you
can't forecast 18 nights away so we'll
take it one night at a time and figure
it out at the end of the day we are
wearing makeup and talk about sports
wait you're wearing makeup all the time
do you have makeup on right now get
makeup on I I do but not for this show
affiliates around the country
however when I do this show on a regular
basis when I'm at home I will go reach
for some powder just for comfort I like
that the new American stars that people
can keep an eye on for the Winter
Olympics will be who Nathan Chen men's
figure skating really jumped on the
scene is athletic ability is
extraordinary of what he's able to pull
number of quads he can do
figure skating turbo Chloe Chloe Kim
with snowboarding she was good enough
but too young to compete for years ago
in Sochi now she's old enough that she's
still good enough to compete so there's
a couple of a young names but you know
what we'll move the meter Lindsey Vonn
Michaela Schiffer and Shaun White
can they come back and do it again I
think there's that always cool mix of
old and new
it makes the Olympics something that
stays fun games after games when do you
fly back I fly back Thursday nights and
then head to South Bend not direct by
the way you cannot go from and we have
Notre Dame wake on Saturday and then
head to Miami and I get to talk to you
on Sunday at 703 when we talk to you
Tony and Rodney highlight of my week
well save travels and we'll talk to you
on Sunday night that's a Mike Tirico
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]